churches have stood here for almost a
thousand years
kiev's lavra Cathedral is one of the
most important Orthodox Christian
institutions in the world
but this year's Christmas service is
different
for the first time the Liturgy is being
delivered in Ukrainian by a recently
formed Ukrainian Orthodox Church
for centuries the Ukrainian Church has
conducted the Christmas service in
ancient Slavic and Russian but times
have changed
I think people have changed the stage is
changing we see historical Justice and
the nation is being formed it's very
important to eradicate everything
Russian from our land it's very
important because
Russian church that was here before they
were supporting like Russian regime
Putin's regime so now when we can have
really Ukrainian Church I'm really glad
to to see it
sentiments like these have been growing
since Russia's illegal annexation of
Crimea and areas of the dombas in 2014
they have now been institutionalized in
a country that's suffering a full-scale
Invasion and more than 10 months of War
as the newly formed Orthodox Church of
Ukraine holds Christmas prayers here for
the first time
the Ukrainian Church affiliated with
Moscow has no choice but to hold a
service at another site close by
Ukraine accuses it of supporting and
even helping Russia in the war something
the church vehemently denies
the priest here is one of a number on a
Ukrainian sanctions list
the police and army have raided numerous
Russian Orthodox Churches across Ukraine
since the war started
Orthodox priest Metropolitan Clement
says his church has no affiliation with
Moscow other than a spiritual one and
accuses Ukraine of flouting its own
Constitution which guarantees freedom of
religion and worship
this is shown by the fact that the
contract for the use of the cathedral by
our church was terminated without
appropriate procedures another
denomination was allowed to conduct the
Christmas service in the church it is
aggressive and discriminatory towards
the worshipers of our church it reminds
us of the situation that existed in the
totalitarian days of the Soviet Union
there are fewer worshipers at this
church on Christmas morning
of course we're a little sad that today
we're not in a cathedral but it's God's
will the main thing is to pray humbly
and then God will decide as needed
Russia's Invasion hasn't only pushed
Ukraine into the arms of the West
further dividing its Orthodox Christian
communities to
Charles Trafford Al Jazeera Kiev